Oh,
how was the Easter break with lice too short?
Come on.
What would be an appropriate lens for
curriculum?
So every time by just two more weeks or something?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I don't know about about uh,
Austria,
but in Hungary,
people usually uh,
go to their friends,
you know,
many people are coming over and we are hanging out with other people and you
always have to drink their stuff.
So if you go there and,
and,
and we have this drink that's called the filing cup.
It's something like the snaps but,
but way stronger.
And I told this to Samsung Austrian people and they were like,
oh my God,
stronger than the synopsis.
How can that be very easily.
At least they are hungry.
So that's how it works.
And you,
you go to the,
to the very first place and you have to drink from their homeroom or full card.
Usually it's very helpful and even as to say something good about it.
So you drink it and it's like,
ah,
but you have to say something good about this because they are,
they're looking at you and you know what,
what would be the reaction?
So you say that it would,
that's,
that's really strong
and then most people seem to be satisfied with that,
so,
right.
This is usually what I say.
But then when,
when you are at like the fifth station for Debbie Day and,
and some people just don't take no for an answer,
unfortunately.
So this,
this is how it goes is it is better in Austria.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's the family part is actually that the nice part.
So we can decide if we drink our own stuff or not.
But,
uh,
I mean my fiance,
his grandfather attempted to make some brooms,
some highly card home and while he did something,
so I mean,
something was created in the process,
but,
uh,
after,
after tasting it,
even,
even the postman didn't want to drink it.
I don't know about postman in Austria,
but in Hungary,
they are like really hardly people.
So they,
they drink whatever they find because,
because obviously you don't,
you don't give the good stuff for the postman.
You,
you give them the leftovers.
So it's like no,
no one dragged out.
So it could be good for the postmark.
And this happened with that.
Imagine that.
Yeah.
Well they are.
Oh they are.
They,
they seem to like alcohol according to my experiences.
So,
um,
and even the postman didn't want to drink that anymore.
So like next time we have seen him around the house and he just came like in,
in front of the main main door and,
and,
and we waved to him.
Hey,
come when we have some for you.
I tell them that.
No,
I'm just going to put them in here immediately.
Okay.
So regarding the assignments,
uh,
you guys are guards have done really well,
so I'm very happy to see that or realize that there is some exponentiality with
respect to the depth of the singing lessons or the more deep ego,
then the more exponential things become.
But this is after like,
I mean it's exponential all along but you don't notice because it starts off
slow.
But after like 10 to 15 boxes,
you can can't,
you can see a very,
uh,
Tommy characteristic of this export control distributor ship.
And,
and many of you have recognized correctly that this is because a refraction and
reflection are sampled all the time.
So whenever I have a bounce,
I am going to,
uh,
compute an intersection and then there's going to be two res perhaps that
continue their way because one is going to be doing the reflection direction and
one is with fractions.
And this quickly gets out of hand because forever ray,
you have to work.
That's the definition of something.
Excellent.
So,
well done.
Let's proceed a bit.
I'm going to talk just a bit about some advanced,
a bit more advanced BRDF models that are mostly used me facing.
So you remember this one version,
the RDF that you see on the right.
And this is the scalar product between Al and Dan.
So the light factor and the normal,
and obviously you can't scale this with Katie,
which is some kind of diffuse up.
No.
Now if you put it next to a really Mitch often diffuse material,
obviously it is a question,
you know,
what do we call it diffuse material or where was this photograph?
How exactly,
but let,
let's disregard this and let,
let's accept that we have this difference between the two.
And if you take a good look then it's becomes apparent that in grazing gambles,
yeah,
does simulated diffuse material seems to be completely taught.
And if you take a look at the formula update and this,
this is a self explanatory because the normal and the light direction and the
normal and the light direction can get perpendicular and then you will,
you will see this darkness.
So there are some advanced BRDF models that try to be a bit more realistic in
this regard.
Such example is the oral nay or model,
which is much closer to what you would it.
You can be locked.
But next notes that all of these simplified BRDF,
smart Dvr,
dof models,
these are all tax.
This is not what physical reality is.
People write up the actual equations that relate to physical reality and trying
to simplify in a way,
but the simple range or can capture and we are going to talk about global
defects and what the real diffuse material looks like in three minutes.
So this RNA or model seems much better and what's even more,
it can take into consideration these Microsoft thick imperfections in different
materials and
you can get a rough nest parameter that can model these imperfections.
What about specular models where the Ford Model T.
Dot.
Our that we have talked about is not the only way to do it.
There is also the phone plane model,
which is a more advanced model and uses this age is how factor it LMP and it
produces different results.
I think this,
this image is maybe not the best because yes the highlights are different,
but one of the main advantage advantages of this material model is that the
shape of the specular reflections can get a bit more elliptic depending on the
viewing direction and the surroundings.
So here you have the very same circular thing.
So it's,
it's not the best example,
but you can see that it's different.
It looks more realistic.
And we still have to think about the fact that these are still really good
models,
that the fees are still,
yeah,
there's also the Cook Torres model that's basically phone blend that can model
also Microsoft office.
And uh,
here maybe with the projector of,
maybe it's not so visible,
but you can see that a specular reflection here is a bit more easier.
So it's not a completely,
uh,
rounds here.
It's not a perfect sphere.
There are these small imperfections that are characteristic to reinforcing
materials.
So this is what this model can capture.
And there are some other advanced BRDF models,
some of which are more easy to understand them implement than it is to pronounce
the name of the authors of the BRDF models.
This is one of those examples.
And this is some kind of in the year model where you have a diffuse substrate
and you have like the coating,
a specular coating.
So there are also be rds for car paint where you can have these sparkly effects.
And there are many BRDF models that capture given.
Perfect.
It's
okay.
Uh,
what if one would like to play with this?
The Disney guys have implemented this program called the BRDF explorer and you
can move many local BRD of models and change the light source positions.
Look at the actual brds and I think Paul's responses.
Give it a try.
So we have always been talking about cameras.
So we are trying to model real world cameras.
If you have a handheld camera you will see a setting that's called the f stop
and the f stop is related to the size of the aperture.
The aperture is the opening of the camera where the light goes in and you can
set this to different values.
And you will notice that if,
if you set this f stop to high value than the aperture of the camera is going to
become smaller.
And if it's smaller than this means that less light is that in and more of the
image that you get is going to be
and vice versa.
So if you have the low f stop setting,
then you will have bigger aperture.
More light is let in and more regions we'll be able to focus.
And this is what gives you this depth of field effect because whatever images we
have seen and created with ray tracers yet don't have this that fulfill the
fact.
But if you use a handheld camera,
then somehow you have to model this effect as well because this is how an image
will be created.
So this is a nice chart made by photograph first
two
see how exactly these f stops relate to aperture size.
What are the typical settings and all of these interesting things
and an actual example.
So let's take a look at the bottom right here.
Okay,
you can see that the whole image is info
and as he adjusts the f stop accordingly.
You can see the top left.
You can see here immediately that the background is heavily blurred.
So this is a more pronounced that fulfilled the fact and it would be wonderful
to have a ray tracer that can take this effect into account.
And this is a ladder,
maybe a bit more beautiful under big,
more visible example.
So at the last time you can see a very pronounced that fulfill the fact that on
the right everything close to everything is in focus.
Yes.
Um,
do you also use the word [inaudible] for computer graphics?
Yes.
And there's also a bunch of papers on how to assimilate this effect.
Some people even try to compute the same your time.
So you have like a computer game,
you would like to see this bouquet effect.
How did you do this?
And you have to take into consideration the depth.
If you know what objects are wearing exactly how far away,
then you can a bunch of trees to,
to,
to get something like that.
And approximation realtime.
Yeah.
And if you do this something that I'm going to show you in a second,
then you will have the very same effect in your age,
race or so on the left completely old focus image on the right you can see again
the depth of field,
the fact,
especially in the background,
the further away you go,
the more you see.
So how do we do this?
Very simple.
Let's skip the text and I just put this here because people who read this at
home,
uh,
we'll know more about this.
So mostly most of what we do is we should or rate through the mid point of the
pixel in Ra tracer and this is going to touch this focal point and then hit an
object.
What we could do is that we will also take samples from nearby.
So not only this big solar,
not only the midpoint but from nearby and should all of these various food,
the same focal point and compute the very same samples.
But these samples will be nearby.
And what we do with the samples is we have reached them and this is what is
going to give you this depth of field.
So this is already some kind of integration.
This means that which if you run a ray tracer and we were going to get a
completely converged image without any noise,
without any problems that that image you can consider dumb.
But this will not be so involved.
Illumination.
This is a speciality of rage racers.
But if you have such an effect,
then you may have to wait until more and more of these samples are computed and
the worst move image you will get,
we will talk about this effect extensively.
It's going to be very important.
And just an important question,
what kind of material model can this be?
Obviously this is some quick,
perhaps open gr preview,
but it's very apparent what I see.
What kind of shading is this?
Yeah.
Is it spiking?
Are,
no,
these are definitely not yours.
Okay.
What else?
Yes,
exactly.
So this is the long version model,
and you can also see this effect that it's goals completely black in the space
and capitals.
Okay.